let's swing it back to schools real
quick because we have this story that's
been going around
utah teacher no longer employed after
advocating vaccination and telling
students she hates trump alpine school
district said that kind of behavior will
not be tolerated the video of her
sharing her opinions in front of a class
at lehigh high school on tuesday was
shared widely on social media and by
wednesday morning the second day of the
new school year alpine school district
in utah county confirmed she wasn't
employed there anymore spokesman david
stevenson said in a statement that he
cannot comment on personnel matters and
would not say whether the teacher was
fired only that she wasn't working there
now she had originally originally been
put on leave tuesday while the district
investigated quote this behavior is
inappropriate not reflective of the
professional conduct and decorum we
expect of our teachers and will not be
tolerated
have you seen the video i haven't i've
seen people sharing i didn't get a
chance to watch it
i uh
i don't agree with this i don't i i
would have loved to have been in that
class
i watched this video she wasn't
screaming at people
she was just giving her opinion and
being loud she was treating the kids
like adults they're high school kids
they're not school children and so you
had you had some you could hear some
guys arguing with her and they were
saying like no no like you know blah
blah and she's like well that's dumb
you're dumb and i'm like man i would
have killed to have had a teacher debate
me or argue with me about politics in
school treating me like an actual you
know like human being instead of just
no shut up you're stupid moving on do as
i say or else she was actually talking
to these kids now her opinions are dumb
they were really bad i just think about
what would have happened if it was the
other way around where a teacher comes
out and says kids like listen you've got
to think for yourselves you've got to
plan ahead just because the media is
saying trump is bad doesn't mean he is
right then all of a sudden they're like
oh no the teacher so i'm fine with the
teacher you know to a certain degree
talking to high school kids
you know about their opinions and
allowing the kids to talk back
i mean i am too
but but you said she called them dumb
for challenging her she did okay so
that's a little bit different right
right i'm all for critical thinking i'm
all for inquiry i'm all for kids
particularly you know of a certain age
challenging pushing back on their
teachers um but when the teacher still
has a role of authority in the classroom
so if it'd be different if she said
let's engage on this issue but if she's
calling them dumb that to me indicates
that she is trying to shut down
discussion not encourage more of it i
just think she's dumb
like she didn't she didn't say shut your
mouth stop talking she she actually
engaged the student and they had like
she wasn't talking over i mean there's a
bit of like argument and stuff of course
but i'm like
man i'd love to be in a classroom where
the students are being like here's what
i think and then she's like well i don't
think me too that sounds like a good
thing for these kids to see that and to
see these people challenging it granted
i still think maybe at the end of
the day teachers shouldn't be going to
classes to argue politics with their
students whether it's for or
it wastes everybody else's time yeah so
listen to that exactly and so as much as
i would have enjoyed arguing with the
teacher and her engaging me i think the
kids are there to be like look we're
going to talk about math and everything
you can talk to your parents about the
political stuff
you can set up you can go in and talk to
the teacher after class if you really
want to
shoot politics and talk about politics
she is a chemistry teacher i don't
really think that she ought to be
talking about politics yeah
honestly she like she squeezes in trump
stuff you know so now we're going to be
dealing with we have sodium here and of
course trump's a salty mf sucks and
anyway um that's sodium chloride by the
way sodium chloride or table salt and
salty like trump and i'll tell you what
that would be funny i i i would enjoy
that you know like the the issue i had
with school was was the the callousness
the cold
the condescension so i watched that
video and i'm like man my schools were
just like shut up you're dumb moving on
well for her to be like well that's don
moore you're dumb i'm kind of like yeah
but she's talking to him and he's
talking back yeah so i think that's like
one thing we need to do with kids is
treat them like they're adults and not
treat them like they're they're stupid
babies i mean i agree with that i i will
say this one i'm surprised it's utah
if you said uh right right
boston or you know philly or
portland or something like that it did
fire her yeah she she did say a couple
things that i think warranted discipline
she said uh most of your parents are
probably stupid or you're you're mo
you're probably smarter than your
parents or your parents are dumber than
you or something like that and she said
and she said don't listen to your
parents you don't have to listen to your
parents see that was a line that's where
schools get into trouble
where they try to undermine the
authority of parents and again that's
one of the big things that i think
may draw people to to home education is
because in many in many respects
everything that we've seen
play out in the last year
um i think has been
a struggle over authority
where we see the state set itself up
against citizens who say
my job is essential
if you mr or mrs governor are drawing a
check during the pandemic
why should i have to forego my pay
when you've seen churches
and local governments
get into struggles over whether churches
can open right again an issue of
authority who
from church's perspective who is the
higher authority is it christ or is it
caesar
and
as it relates to education it's schools
setting themselves up as a higher
authority than parents listen to us
right we know better we went to school
we have master's degree
degrees don't listen to your parents and
i think
for whatever reason parents have
accepted that that is the natural order
of things in college but when schools
start doing that with kids as early as
three and introducing them to things
that their parents don't necessarily
know about i'll give an example in in
many school districts
if a child
sort of exhibits signs of not even
gender dysphoria if the child says
i'm questioning my gender
the schools will allow a child to
socially transition they'll use a
different name different pronouns in the
school
but then not only will they not tell the
parents when the parents come around
they will call jimmy jimmy
in front of his parents to hide it to
hide it and i think when you start to
open
those types of doors all different types
of things can come through we had a
woman on the show she was showing us a
bunch of books the critical race applied
principle books and one of them was uh
it was called was it not my idea yeah
and it was it was azra
not my idea
yeah yeah have you seen the book not my
idea i have not known it's this little
girl who looks like she's six or seven
years old and she says like one day
mommy was watching a video on the
computer of a policeman and i and then
when i came up she covers it and you
know something like that and then you
know later on
there's this they show this picture
called the whiteness contract or
whatever it's a contract with a devil
tale and it says you'll steal from your
neighbors and whatever
and then she says you know at the end a
little girl's in the car he starts
screaming i you know no you're lying to
me you're lying to me tell me the truth
i know the truth and the mother is like
oh no what's happening okay i guess i'll
tell you the whole book was basically
priming children to
defy what their parents were teaching
them
we have seen
uh these teachers post these videos
where they say we are going to teach
your kids things you don't want them to
yeah there was the the gay men's choir
yeah that viral video
tongue-in-cheek whatever they want to
call it they said we're coming for your
kids over and over again thinking it was
funny but then they said like all the
things you don't want them exposed to
we're going to expose them to and
they're friends and everything and it's
like dude parents have a right to choose
for their children what's best for them
you do not own these kids yeah but
that's that's the saying the left
doesn't have any kids they have yours
that's good yeah that's good even you
know there's a there's a show that my
kids like um it's called bubble guppy so
if you've got any parents out there who
have young children they'll know what is
what it's about and
they had rupaul
voice over a character
um in one of the episodes so the whole
show takes place underwater so the
characters are like you know mini
mermaids and fish and stuff like that
and at one point one of the characters
they were talking about getting dressed
during the day and they said yeah it's a
real drag and you could tell that you
know they're trying to let the kids the
adults in on the joke right
and for me the way i think about it
in terms of the analogy that i would use
is that
um
there's a lot of different ways
to um
to cook a steak i'll say it that way
right
but when you first pull it out of the
fridge it's not ready for frying pan
so you can pulverize it
or you can tenderize it
and you pulverize with policy and you
tenderize with culture
and and really what the left is trying
to do in terms of their tenderizing
is
marinate us in these things and they
want to get the kids in as young as
possible you know because when you're
being marinated you know the spices and
you know the aroma and it smells good
and you think it tastes good
but those fibers that have been so tough
and and so
um
unforgiving for a long time are being
sort of broken down and that's how you
get people who are open to ideas
whatever the transgression is because
left is all about subversion of any sort
of social norm
um and i think that's what you're seeing
and that's the reason why they think
it's appropriate to have rupaul on a
show for kids that's you know from two
to seven years old we covered the story
australia is building alternative
quarantine hubs with relocatable cabins
they call it
sounds like a camp right and so the idea
is that oh the hotels weren't working so
we're gonna build a hub for people to
quarantine in and we're gonna have
color-coded communities so that we know
what area they're in
and we had people on super chat saying
oh come on tim we tried quarantining
people in hotels and it wasn't working
so we're just making something more
efficient and i'm like yeah that's
called incrementalization right it's
where they're like
you are now defending the camp because
it's within your reasonable boundaries
and the funny thing is i've long
explained the function of uh moral
manipulation what through what's called
um
it's resetting resetting a person's
boundaries right
so the way to describe it is imagine
there's a scale of negative 100 to
positive 100 and then you're at zero
negative 100 means you absolutely
despise a person to the point where you
would physically harm them and positive
100 means marriage in a family mm-hmm
you're at zero
a person's reasonable boundaries only go
from negative 10 to positive 10. you can
only so what that means is you can't
walk up to a random person and say you
know go hit that guy they're going to be
like what i'm no i don't know that's
right or go kiss go kiss that person
right they're going to be like no that's
that's insane but you can say slightly
in one direction or the other like hey
that person called you a mean name or
hey that person
made a nice compliment and you move them
within that boundary after a certain
amount of time in that in that space
their boundaries reset oh yeah so this
is how they incrementalize you right if
if three years ago they announced we're
gonna be building a major quarantine
camp to with relocatable cabins to house
high-risk populations people would be
like
but you start with the hotels and then
you go oh no the hotels are such a
disaster and then people go well just
build a place then you're right we'll
build a place it was your idea right
right right that makes more sense yeah
and it depends on who's building it if
trump was building the hotel oh yeah it
would be a very very different reaction
than
you know if if biden builds them so i i
think
i think what you described is sort of
the the overton window put into practice
for people right you know and and i
think a lot of us have been moved
in one direction or the other and you
can see
it's almost like for some people they
they have a desire to be controlled by
the government right it's like they're
looking well well
and i found this particularly after
after people started getting vaccinated
where i would hear people say i'm fully
vaccinated but i'm double masking while
i'm riding my bicycle and nobody's
around in the woods
why would you do that well
some health professionals said i should
like don't you think you have the
ability to make your own rational
decisions and
it's it's unfortunate because i think
again all of these things are linked
because a lot
a lot of us have not learned to think
critically
to to challenge authority
um you know in whatever respectful way
whatever that looks like
and i think you're starting to see the
byproduct of that you know in our
country thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you